[Music]
mahito
so you made
it mother have a
seat it's this way
mahito a lot of strange things happen in
this place join us I just hope he stays
safe
save me save me my what exactly are
you dear Mother she's awaiting your
rescue I'll be your
guide what is this
place this world is filled with the
dead I know it's a lie but I have to see
I'm looking for
someone let's
go we must protect this world ourselves
go back now Mel
Mel you and I aren't BS or Allies
kids don't let go no matter what
[Music]
ready see this
world there's more work to be
[Music]
done a gray Heron once told me that all
gray herens are liars so is that the
truth or a lie
a have to be alive
[Music]
too